the text now clarifies passenger rights
in the situations when the plane is
canceled or delayed the air carriers
burden of proof has been clarified we
also found a good compromise on hand
luggage rules and extraordinary
circumstances the political pillar of
the fourth wave a package which was the
core topic of today's council and I have
a confidence now that we reach a point
where we can really finalize the
negotiation together with the
Commissioner ettinger we invited
ministers this morning to exchange of
views and to discuss the readiness to
abolish roaming fees and agree on the
principles for open Internet within
European Union based on that I can
reaffirm that the council fully supports
the abolishment of the roaming
surcharges and we fully support the
establishment of the first open Internet
rules for the whole European Union the
many events in the last few weeks the
attack probably from Isis tourism
tourists on TV segments in France where
a broadcaster lap was taken off air for
several hours and then the recent attack
on the German parliament a site that
shows us very clearly that data security
and safety plate security of our digital
systems combating industrial espionage
combating terroristic attacks or hacker
attacks on digital infrastructure all of
these are coming more and more important